one of my sons i won't say which one was  taking long showers and i just had to  tell him  hey i can't  and he was like what i go look don't  maybe  say but i know what's happening in the  shower and he was like  i don't know what you're talking about  because they deny whatever and i go  all right listen i know you're taking  really long showers because you're  masturbating in the shower and he was  like  what and i was like i told you  i was going to say it to your face now  what i'm telling you is  i don't want to have to pay that water  bill  do you know what i'm saying like this is  not  working for me just go jerk off in your  room  totally acceptable at all times that's  why we knock and all that [ __ ]  you know i assume when your door's shut  you're jerking off  i think he got it he got it i think he  got it